we now start with our agenda of
developing continuous counterparts of
everything we have done for discrete
random variables let us look at the
concept of expectation in the discrete
case we have defined expectation as a
weighted average of the values X of the
random variable weighted according to
their corresponding probabilities in the
continuous case we define expectation in
a similar way as a weighted average of
the possible values of X weighted
according to the corresponding value of
the density points where the density is
higher for example here will receive a
higher weight in this calculation but of
course since we are averaging over a
continuous set the summation will have
to be replaced by an integral this will
be a recurrent theme in this unit
definitions or formulas for the
continuous case look exactly like the
discrete ones except that pmf's are
replaced by densities as here the PMF is
replaced by a density and summations are
replaced by integrals the intuition is
usually the same in both the discrete
and the continuous case however the
intuition is usually much clearer much
easier to visualize in the discrete case
so the best strategy is to make sure to
understand fully the intuition for the
discrete case and just rely on it at
this point let me add some fine print a
mathematical side point this integral or
the expectation will not be always
well-defined for this integral to make
sense we will need to make the
assumption that the integral of the
absolute value of little X who waited
according to the density gives us a
finite result unless we explicitly say
something different we will always
assume that we're dealing with random
variables that satisfy this condition
and so the expectation is well-defined
mathematically coming back to the big
picture regarding expect
patience the intuition remains the same
as in the discrete case that the
expectation represents the average of
the values we expect to see in a very
large number of independent repetitions
of the experiment in fact there are also
theorems to this effect but these will
have to wait until later in this class
when we study limit theorems another
intuitive interpretation that is true
for both of the discrete and the
continuous case is that the expectation
corresponds to the center of gravity of
the probability distribution so in this
diagram it might be somewhere around
here and similarly for the continuous
diagram the center of gravity might be
somewhere around here and if it happens
that the distribution the PMF for the
PDF happens to be symmetric around a
certain point then that point will be
equal to the expectation expectations of
continuous random variables have all the
properties you might expect for example
non-negative random variables have
non-negative expectations
random variables that lie inside an
interval have average values or
expectations that also lie inside the
same interval the derivation is exactly
the same as for the discrete case there
is also an expected value rule in the
discrete case it took on this form in
the continuous case we obtain an
analogous form in which the summation is
replaced by integral and instead of
weighing according to the PMF we now
weigh according to the density function
the derivation of the expected value
rule for the continuous case is a little
more complicated than the one that we
gave from the discrete case but it's
sufficient for us to know that it is
true and that it has an intuitive
meaning that runs along the same lines
as the intuitive meaning that we had for
the discrete case as an instance of how
we might apply the expected value role
if you wish to calculate the expected
value of the square of a continuous
random variable you would proceed as
follows
you would integrate over the entire real
line the value of the function which is
X square in our case weighted according
to the density finally a most important
property of expectations is linearity
linearity is still true for continuous
random variables as well and the way it
is derived is exactly the same as in the
discrete case namely we apply the
expected value rule to this function of
the random variable X and separate out
the various terms the stories regarding
variances is exactly the same as in the
discrete case we define variances using
the same definition and of course here
mule stands for the expected value of
the random variable X to calculate the
variance we can use the expected value
rule which takes this form in the
continuous case and we apply the
expected value rule for the case where
we're dealing with the expected value of
this particular function so that in this
instance the function G of X is X minus
mu squared so by applying the expected
value rule we obtain the integral from
minus infinity to infinity the function
G of X weighted according to the density
and then we carry out the integration we
also define the standard deviation same
way as in the discrete case we have a
property about the variance of linear
functions of a random variable namely
that if we add a constant to a random
variable this has no effect on the
variance but if we multiply a random
variable by a constant the variance gets
multiplied by the square of that
constant finally when calculating the
variance it is often convenient to use
this alternative formula in which the
variance is calculated by finding the
expected value of the square of the
random variable and also using the
expected value of the random variable
but square
and subtracted from the first term this
relation and this relation are both
derived exactly the same way as in the
discrete case and there is no reason to
repeat those derivations